now Libya's been torn apart by fighting
since longtime ruler Muammar Qaddafi was
overthrown in 2011 it's divided between
militia groups which mostly back to
rival governments the UN recognized
administration led by Prime Minister
Faisal Suraj's based in Tripoli is
supported by Turkey and most Western
nations including Italy which is worried
the fighting near Tripoli will force
more people to cross the Mediterranean
in the east
there is the Tobruk based governments
the center of powerful warlord Holly for
Haftarah
he's backed by Egypt Saudi Arabia Russia
and the United Arab Emirates France is
also accused of providing military
support to his forces in a moment we'll
be speaking to Jamal a trial was in
Turkey's capital Ankara but first we go
to our correspondent in Moscow step
passing so step tell us about who is in
Moscow and how we're expecting things to
play out since Monday well the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs spokeswoman has now
confirmed on Facebook that both leaders
are actually inside the foreign
ministry's building
Siraj arrived earlier this morning and
after was already here since last night
and they will join as she writes the
meeting that's ongoing now between the
ministers of Foreign Affairs and defense
of Russia and Turkey so there is this
suggestion that they will all be in the
same room together soon we have to wait
and see what is the aim of this meeting
is that there will be signatures put
under the ceasefire agreement which was
brokered between Russia and Turkey in
Istanbul last week and it's also alleged
that Egypt and the United Arab Emirates
will have delegates to witness this
ceasefire agreement the ministry has
said that there will be a long meeting
so we don't expect anything soon but the
talks are ongoing now and interestingly
of course that this peace deal this this
power broker agreement is done by Turkey
and Russia and has come across very
quickly now in the last couple of days
talk to us more step about the role of
Russia in Libya and the significance of
Russian mediation in this conflict why
Russia is
keen to see an end to the war in Libya
well it's interesting how quickly Russia
and President Putin has managed to put
himself in the position of a power
broker in Libya because we have to
remember Russia has been backing a
halifa
after the warlord since 2016 quietly
some Libyan money has been printed here
in Moscow for his informal a government
in the east of Libya and also some
logistical support was given but only
since September Russian mercenaries
arrived more in more numbers in Libya
and actually have contributed to the
fight more weapons have been delivered
and that actually has changed the Power
Balance in Libya to the extent that now
Turkey which is backing the the UN
backed government and Russia are now
have become the main power brokers and
Russia has always supported NAFTA with
the idea that he is a strong man who can
actually oppose Islamic extremism but I
also have kept open the communication
with with the un-backed government it's
it's not only for Putin to be this peace
mediator but they're also of course
economic interest at stake and there's
supposed to be some kind of deals
between Turkey and Russia about oil
fields in Libya as well thank you very
much for that steadfast in life for us
in Moscow let's now go to Jamaa relish
Eyal who's in Ankara Turkey for us
Jamal as we said Libya's conflict has
drawn conflicting involvement from
foreign powers not just the Russians and
the Turks but also other countries Italy
France and to a lesser extent the
Americans what's in it for Turkey and
how soon could we see a political
settlement to this conflict well there's
a lot at stake here for Turkey from
different perspectives in terms of the
fact that both Libya and Turkey share
maritime borders in the Mediterranean
Sea they have now several bilateral
agreements that they have signed between
the two governments in recent months the
mutual defense agreements as well as one
looking at the demarcation of those
borders in the Mediterranean Sea to
allow for joint extraction of natural
resources from there and if we continue
looking at
strategically across the Mediterranean
Sea talking about the flow of a lot of
VP refugees who will be leaving North
Africa coming towards Europe there is a
large part that Turkey is concerned with
or that would implicate Turkey as well
so there's a lot as far as the Turks are
concerned but also beyond that when you
look at Turk his own strategic foreign
policy objectives in terms of trying to
find some sort of balance of power
within the wider Middle East and North
Africa region because prior to Turkey's
maybe come coming to the forefront of
the the the situation in Libya you
didn't really have that power balance
you had people who were supporting
half-thought namely the United Arab
Emirates and Egypt and others who
believed that there needed to be a
reversal of the clock from the Arab
Spring of 2011 and a reinstatement of
these strong men as step was talking
about military individuals who
essentially would continue the status
quo of autocratic regimes in their in
the Arab world whereas Turkey maybe says
it pushes I believe that there needs to
be more pluralism
in societies and in the political
discourse and therefore it was trying to
reach that power balance but what's
significance here is that turkey in this
instance doesn't seem to be working
alone we have the Italian prime minister
now coming to Ankara in the next couple
of hours to meet with the president so
Giuseppe Conte will be meeting with I
want to discuss obviously their views on
how to move forward this ceasefire as
significant as it may be will also be
accompanied with a lot of caution
because whilst there will be an
agreement to stop the fighting there
isn't an agreement to give up arms and
the fact that you would have a country
the size of Libya with the history of
Libya as well as obviously the other
intricate details that form the social
construct of Libya in terms of tribalism
and so forth that there would be two
separate entities that have their own
militia that they have their own weapons
I have their own ability to print
currencies all of that is going to make
it very difficult to see how a ceasefire
could hold for a very long time without
there being a longer-term agreement to
either form some sort of national unity
government or at least to try and start
the arming or rather on
some of these on groups Thank You Jamar
for that Jamal is Cheyenne in Ankara
Turkey force